uh good afternoon everyone uh it is as
always a great pleasure to welcome the
Secretary General back to to Washington
back to the state department Jens
uh so good to be with you um
before I begin and with your permission
I just want to briefly update everyone
on our efforts to assist turkey in Syria
in the aftermath of Monday's earthquakes
um
the loss of life has been truly
staggering
shocking
um we uh I think along with people
around the world
our morning those have been lost and uh
also our thoughts are so with those who
have lost loved ones
um so far we've deployed more than 150
search and rescue Personnel to Turkey we
have U.S helicopters that are helping to
reach areas that would otherwise be
difficult to access
in Syria we have NGO partners that we
funded over the years that are providing
life-saving assistance to those in need
across both countries
uh We've deployed experienced emergency
managers hazardous materials technicians
Engineers logisticians paramedics
planners others along with about 170 000
pounds of specialized tools and
equipment
so that's been the initial response in
the days ahead we'll have more to say
about how we'll continue to support both
the Turkish and Syrian people as they
work to recover from this devastation
turning back to today the Secretary
General and I were last together in
November for the NATO foreign ministers
meeting
the members of our alliance left that
meeting in Bucharest even more unified
more Resolute and more committed in our
support for Ukraine which is in large
part due to the remarkable leadership
that Secretary General stoltenberg has
engaged in over over the last year
during what has been a decisive time for
NATO and for the world
his strong and steady hand has helped
steer our alliance in the right
direction
now as we approach the one-year Mark
since President Putin launched his
brutal war against Ukraine it's critical
that we maintain and increase that
support
uh President Putin's War continues to be
a strategic failure
he's failed to overthrow the
democratically elected government of
Ukraine he's failed to subsume Ukraine
into Russia or to break the will of his
people
he's lost the battles for key for Hakeem
for her son his military is suffering
staggering losses on the battlefield
and he's failed to weaken our alliance
and what it stands for in fact that
Alliance NATO is stronger and more
united than it's ever been
today we focused on steps that we can
take to ensure that Ukraine has the
security assistance that it needs to
defend its territory against Russian
aggression and we'll continue that
conversation this afternoon when we're
joined by the Secretary of Defense but
Austin and the National Security advisor
Jake Sullivan here at the state
department
we've calibrated our assistance to meet
Ukraine's changing needs from the
outside of the Russian invasion and
that's exactly what we'll continue to do
two weeks ago President Biden announced
that the United States would send
Abram's tanks to you Craig Germany
committed to send his sleep apart tanks
and authorize other partners to do the
same
this followed the earlier Announcement
by the United Kingdom that it would be
sending Challenger two tanks to
Ukraine's Defenders
last week we also announced two new
assistance packages which will provide
critical air defense and counter drone
capabilities to help Ukraine defend its
people including against the threat
posed by uavs supplied by Iran which
shares Russia's authoritarian vision and
is increasingly aiding and abetting its
aggression
we're also providing armored infantry
vehicles and more of the equipment that
Ukraine is using so effectively like
Javelin anti-tank missiles artillery
ammunition and Rockets for U.S provided
by Mars in total the United States has
committed nearly 30 billion dollars
since the beginning of Russia's Invasion
and our allies and partners have
provided more than 13 billion dollars in
military assistance over the past year
and tens of billions more in
humanitarian and economic support the
contributions that Europe at large has
made to this effort are very significant
and making a profound difference
as president zielinski has said
diplomacy is the only way to
definitively end Russia's war of
aggression and to create a path to peace
that is both just and durable
clearly President Putin has no genuine
interest in diplomacy right now
here's what he said just a few weeks ago
unless and until Ukraine accepts the new
territorial realities in quotation marks
there's nothing to even talk about
in other words Ukraine and the world
must somehow acquiesce to President
Putin's land grant
that should be a non-starter for every
country in the world that cares about
the UN Charter and preserving
International Peace and security
the best way to hasten prospects for
real diplomacy is to keep tilting the
battlefield in Ukraine's favor
this will help ensure that Ukraine has
the strongest possible hand to play at a
negotiating table when one emerges
we also discussed the
stomach and tactical challenges that
China presents to the alliance and the
broader International System
uh last week Beijing violated
international law and U.S sovereignty
with the presence of a Chinese
surveillance balloon in U.S airspace
this was an irresponsible Act
in response to which we acted
responsibly and prudently to protect our
interests
there is an ongoing operation to recover
the balloons components we're analyzing
them to learn more about the
surveillance program
we'll pair that with what we learned
from the balloon what we learned from
the balloon itself with what we glean
based on our careful observation of the
system when it was in our airspace as
the president directed his team to do
I will also share relevant findings with
Congress as well as with our allies and
partners around the world
senior Administration officials are on
the hill this week and we already shared
information with dozens of countries
around the world both from Washington
and through our embassies we're doing so
because the United States was not the
only target of this broader program
which has violated the sovereignty of
countries across five continents
in our engagements we are again hearing
from our partners that the world expects
China in the United States to manage our
relationship responsibly that's
precisely what we set out to do we
continue to urge China to do the same
we're also continuing to strengthen and
broaden NATO's Partnerships and weave
them together in new ways the United
States welcomed the secretary General's
visit to South Korea and Japan last week
as an extension of those efforts
demonstrating the growing Synergy
between our Atlantic and Pacific
alliances
and of course we're very focused on the
accession of Sweden and Finland to Nato
these countries are ready to bring their
strengths to bear on our alliance
they're capable they're trusted Partners
they're strong democracies that are
dedicated to the values that underpin
the alliance will continue to push for
the completion of this process as we
head toward the villainous Summit in
July
and as we look to Vilnius our alliance
is working to operationalize the
Strategic concept to make sure that NATO
is fit for the future including on
challenges like emerging Technologies
cyber defense climate and energy
security these were all significant
achievements under the leadership of
Secretary General stoltenberg in
bringing forward and having approved a
new strategic concept for the alliance
to reflect the realities of the moment
we're living in and to project what we
need to do into the future so it's a
busy time but we're confident about what
our lives can achieve confident because
of the great Unity that we've shown
again and again over the last year and
confident because of the shared purpose
we bring to the year and the years ahead
with that yes over to you
it's great to be back in Washington and
to be together with you again I would
like to start by commending President
Biden and United States for providing
such strong leadership at the time when
we Face the most serious security crisis
in a generation
and thank you Tony for your personal
commitment and your leadership
on every issue related to Nato and the
vital bond between America and Europe
unwavering American leadership and
bipartisan support have ensured that
NATO allies are united like never before
and our Unity makes a real difference
President Putin launched his illegal War
regression almost a year ago
since then NATO allies have provided
unprecedented support for Ukraine around
120 billion dollars in military
humanitarian and financial assistance
as the biggest Ally the United States is
playing an indispensable role in
supporting Ukraine
European NATO allies and Canada have
stepped up as well contributing over
half of the overall assistance including
tanks Advanced Air Defense systems and
other military equipment
Europeans have also welcomed almost 5
million refugees from Ukraine applied
unprecedented sanctions and decoupled
from Russian gas and Russian oil
this shows how much we can do when
Europe and North America Stand Together
today we discussed the situation in
Ukraine
Putin started this war of aggression and
he can end this war today by withdrawing
his troops from Ukraine and coming to
the negotiating table
but regrettably we see no sign that
Russia is preparing for peace on the
contrary Moscow is preparing for new
military offensives
so we must continue to provide Ukraine
with the weapons it needs to retake
territory and Prevail as a sovereign
independent nation
if Putin wins it would be a tragedy for
Ukraine
but it will also be dangerous for all of
us it will send a clear message not just
to put in but also to other
authoritarian regimes that when they use
Force they can achieve their goals
that will make the world more dangerous
and all of us more vulnerable
Beijing is watching closely
and learning lessons
that may influence its future decisions
so what happens in Europe today could
happen in Asia tomorrow
China is substantially building up its
military forces
including nuclear weapons without any
transparency
it is attempting to search control over
the South China Sea and threatening
Taiwan
try to take control of critical
infrastructure including in NATO
countries
repressing its own citizens and
trampling on human rights
and deepening its strategic partnership
with Moscow
so NATO allies had real concerns which
we discussed today
in this more dangerous and more
competitive world we must continue to
strengthen our deterrence and events
and further increase defense spending
and that is what we are doing
in 2014 under the Obama Biden
Administration
all NATO allies agreed the defense
investment pledge
since then we have seen eight
consecutive years of increased defense
spending across Europe and Canada
with an additional 350 million extra U.S
dollar spent
more countries are now spending at least
two percent of GDP on defense
and I expect that Trend to continue
today we also discussed the importance
of completing Finland and Sweden's
accession to Nato
at the Madrid Summit last July all
allies made a historic decision to
invite both countries to join NATO
all allies have signed the accession
protocols and 28 allies have already
ratified the agreement
Finland and Sweden are now being
integrated into the civilian and
Military structures of our alliance
this has already strengthened their
security
and it is inconceivable that allies will
not act should Finland or Sweden come
under pressure
it is important that we conclude this
membership membership process as soon as
possible
this will strengthen the security of all
allies
so secretary blinken their Tony thank
you again for your strong personal
commitment
and uh for the extraordinary ship of the
United States as we Face Global
challenges together
questions we will start with Leon
Bruneau of the AFP
hi there Mr secretary and Secretary
General thanks for doing this
um Mr secretary you you started the
press conference speaking about the
tragic earthquake in turkey and Syria
and actually that's my question is
relevant to that
um specifically uh as you know there's
uh one border crossing in the northwest
of Syria which is damaged by the
earthquake and there are no other
Crossings and so obviously it's going to
be difficult to to get the aid there and
you also said that you were adamant
saying that all USA would go through
local ngos
and so my question is this is I was
wondering if the Administration has had
any contact at any level with the Syrian
government
and if there were a request through the
Syrian government would the U.S the
administration exceed to that request to
coordinate aid for their Syrian people
and a question from the Secretary
General
um since turkey is obviously a NATO
member
could you provide us some detail on what
NATO is actually doing to help the
recovery efforts in turkey and also
tragically
with this tragedy in any way help to
ease tensions with turkey on relevant
issues that you mentioned on your agenda
thank you very much
now thank you very much
um with regard to Syria I'm not aware of
any contacts between the United States
government and the Syrian government in
in recent days since the the earthquake
but here's what uh here's what we've
been doing
if you go back
to 2011.
we provided more than 15 billion dollars
in assistance to the Syrian people
through NGO Partners International NGO
partners partners on the ground in Syria
we're a leading provider of humanitarian
assistance to Syria to the Syrian people
not to the government and working
through these Partners we've tried to
make sure that the assistance gets to
where it's needed and that's the people
who are affected by the horrific war
that Assad has waged on his own people
since 2011 and now in the case of the
earthquake to people affected by the
earthquake you're exactly right that
there is one Crossing that allows
assistance to get into Syria from the
from the outside and that was disrupted
by the earthquake it's exactly why we
have been fighting every single year not
only to preserve that Crossing at the
end it's authorized as you know by the
United Nations but to get additional
ones so that if a Crossing was taken out
of action there would be other places
that people could get humanitarian
assistance and of course year after year
Russia has sought to block those
Crossings or to limit them and that only
compounds the tragedy that people in
Syria are now experiencing
just a couple of hours after the
earthquake we sent out a coal from the
NATO headquarters to all NATO allies to
provide immediate support to help turkey
with the consequence of devastating
earthquake and I welcome that allies
have stepped up and are now providing
different types of support of course the
U.S Secretary Lincoln mentioned has
already provided a lot of support but
also other allies are stepping up and
and that's the continued message from
from NATO is that we should support
turkey valued and important NATO Ally
where we see human suffering and the
devastating consequences of the
earthquake and of course allies also
expressed the deepest condolences and
it is the heartbreaking to see all the
suffering but also to see how people on
allies are not stepping up to provide as
much help as possible
Vero gas and RK
question for secretary blinken how
important is it for the Biden
Administration that Sweden is also
allowed to join NATO not just Finland
and what is the U.S doing to solve this
this argument with erdogan and turkey
what how can the U.S influence that
turkey changes its position
thank you well first this is not a
bilateral issue between the United
States and any other country
this is a an alliance matter and our
view is very clear
both Finland and Sweden are ready to be
NATO allies and the alliance should
welcome them as quickly as possible
their militaries already work seamlessly
with uh with Alliance forces
as I said earlier they're strong vibrant
democracies
we're confident that NATO will formally
welcome both countries and that that
will happen soon and this will in turn
enhance security across the entire
euro-atlantic region
as this process continues we are fully
committed to Finland and Sweden's
accession to the alliance and again I
think you can see the strength of that
support across the alliance nearly all
countries took Swift action our Senate
overwhelmingly and on a bipartisan basis
voted for their membership and the time
is right now to finalize that accession
process and to welcome as full members
of NATO we support the work that both
countries have been doing with turkey to
address legitimate concerns that turkey
has brought to the table about its
security there's an ongoing process
there but as you know both countries
Finland and Sweden took significant
steps to address concerns that the
turkey raised they made commitments
under a memorandum of agreement that was
signed Madrid and they're making good on
on the commitments that they've made
again we acknowledge turkey's longtime
security concerns we appreciate the
tangible actions that both countries
Finland and Sweden have taken to address
Nick schifrin of PBS
thank you very much Mr secretary for
giving me two questions uh for you and
then I'll turn to the Secretary General
that today the British prime minister
announced that the UK would provide
fighter jet training Western fighter jet
training to Ukrainian piloton would
examine the possibility of providing
Western Jets to Ukraine why does the U.S
continue to oppose
a step that the British government now
believes would be helpful to Ukraine
long term and on the balloon you've
described now the network of aerial
surveillance conducted by China in five
continents do you believe that that
network is run by the pla Air Force and
do you believe Xi Jinping himself was
aware of the balloon last week and Mr
Secretary General U.S officials have
described that Chinese surveillance
balloons have flown over at least one
European country is that something that
NATO is aware of and are you concerned
about thank you
um thank you very much
so first of all with regard to the
balloon we will have more to say about
that in the in the days ahead we are
getting more information almost by the
hour as we continue to work to salvage
the balloon we're learning from that and
as well we're learning from
what we saw and picked up as the balloon
traversed the the United States as to
who's responsible for that
um
China is
and it doesn't matter on one level which
individuals may or may not have been
have been responsible the fact is China
engaged in this irresponsible action
violation of our our sovereignty and
territorial integrity
and
international law
and as we've noted as well we're not
alone in this countries across five
continents have also had surveillance
balloons overfly their territory which
is why we're sharing this information
with others we continue to look to China
to act responsibly and uh as well to
help us in managing this relationship
responsibly that's what we continue uh
to look for and I'm sorry the first part
of your question oh the fighter jets
um
as we've said
throughout this process
and every single turn we will working
very closely with the ukrainians as well
as working with other partners and
allies
work to make sure that Ukraine has what
it needs when it needs it to effectively
defend itself
and to continue to take back the
territory that's been seized from it by
Russian forces as the
nature of the uh the conflict of the
aggression has evolved so too is the
support that we provided and what we did
initially in fact before the Russian
aggression itself as we saw as we saw it
coming and wanted to make sure that
Ukraine had in its hands what it would
need to defend itself we did these very
significant drawdowns a year you know
more than well more than Euro a year and
a half ago back in September before the
aggression Christmas before the
aggression and as a result they had
things like stingers and javelins on
hand when Russia went at Kiev and they
were able to repel the attack and and
push it back
at every step along the way
as needs have evolved so too is what we
have provided Ukraine and that most
recently
um
took place with the decision to provide
the Abrams tanks and of course Germany
providing the leopard tanks and other
Europeans
doing the same
we've also been very clear all along
that what's vital is not just a
particular weapon system
piece of equipment equally important is
the ability of ukrainians to use it
effectively and that requires in some
cases significant training equally
important is the ability to maintain it
and then finally all of that has to be
brought together in an actually in a
coherent strategy all of those elements
are important it's a long way of saying
this this is an evolving process and we
will continue to make judgments about
what we think Ukraine needs and what it
can be most effective and using will do
that in very close consultation with
ukrainians and of course in consultation
with our partners
the Chinese balloon over the United
States confirms a pattern of Chinese
Behavior where we see that China over
the last years has invested heavily in
new military capabilities including
different types of surveillance and
intelligence platforms and we've also
seen increased Chinese intelligence
activities in Europe again different
platforms
they use satellites they they use cyber
and as we've seen of the United States
also balloons so so we just have to be
vigilant we need to be aware of the
constant risk over Chinese intelligence
and then step up what we do to protect
ourselves
and we need also to react in a in a
prudent responsible and Vigilant way as
we have seen in the United States has
reacted to this specific balloon over
North America and United States I think
it also highlights that security is not
Regional security is global what happens
in Asia matters for Europe and what
happens in Europe matters for Asia and
and also of course for North America
this was a message that was very much
confirmed during my visit to Japan and
South Korea East Asia last week where
those close partners of of NATO very
much highlighted the importance of
strengthening the cooperation between
NATO and and our partners in in in the
Pacific to address the challenges that
China poses to our security to our
values and and our interests and I think
that is the balloon over North America
just confirms that pattern
take a final question from Karen
Erickson of indeed
thank you very much so um back to Turkey
then because turkey is now sending the
signal that it might accept Finland but
not Sweden into NATO separating the
processes I wanted to ask you both to
what extent do you see this is a
possible or viable path forward thank
you
first of all I think you have to
remember that all allies also turkey
made an historic decision in July last
year when all allies at the NATO Summit
in Madrid invited both Finland and
Sweden to become members of The Alliance
then all allies all 30 allies signed the
accession protocols and so far already
28 out of 30 allies have ratified the
accession protocols these are historic
decisions
and so far this has been
one of the quickest accession processes
in NATO's history and the quickest in
NATO's modern history because we have to
remember that Finland Sweden applied in
May last year and only in July they were
invited and and now 28 out of 30 have
ratified the the protocols they apply
together they were invited together and
and and 28 allies are all designed both
protocols
um I think it's important that we
recognize the the importance both for
Finland and Sweden but also for for the
whole Alliance and that they become a
member uh because that they will become
members as as quickly as possible
um as part of the decision in um in in
Madrid Finland Sweden and turkey has
signed the joint memorandum on how to
step up cooperation not least in the
fight against terrorism Finland and
Sweden have delivered on their
commitments under that memorandum I also
expressed that view in my meetings with
the Turkish leadership so I'm confident
that both will become a member but I'm
not ready to go into exactly when that
will happen
um what he said
thank you gentlemen thank you